welcome can you guys all hear me if
you're not from Carnegie Mellon welcome
if you are thank you for coming to this
kickoff event this morning my name is J
Whittaker I'm the director of the Wilton
East Scotts Institute for energy
innovation here at CMU and it is my
distinct honor to kick off energy week
right now I hope that this is the first
of many very interesting sessions we are
starting with the bang we've got some
extraordinary people and in a quick
succession followed by an excellent
keynote address and I'll let the folks
who are about to introduce in series
introduce each other so I'm not going to
spoil or take any of their thunder my
job here today right now is to provide a
bit of context I am the as I say Scott
Institute is our endowed thing here at
CMU to encourage could interconnect and
synergize energy research within the CMU
community there was a tremendous amount
of this kind of work already going on at
CMU prior to the founding of the Scott
Institute and so the job that we have
here is to connect synergize create more
out of the pieces than would have been
without us right
Wilton Scott R is the father of Sherman
Scott who was our the prime named funder
of the Institute and he has created for
us a number of funding mechanisms to
make things real here one of which is
some outreach money that supports energy
week and so we are here today and in the
name of the Scott's to create a lot of
interest synergy and communication
between all the stakeholders within the
University and outside of the University
so please one of our biggest priorities
is to have you all talk amongst
yourselves after enduring sessions if
you can if something happens up here
someone says something that's exciting
to you reach out afterwards we have a
lot of receptions we have time for
communication that is our deal it the
more connections we make the more
interest we bring in everybody wins and
so this is sort of part and parcel what
we're trying to do
and I don't have a whole lot else to say
except for the next person who is going
to give the next introduction is the
newly finalized actual president of
Carnegie Mellon University Farnum
Jahannam Farnum was appointed the tenth
president of CMU by its board of
trustees in March he's previously the
university's provost and later served as
interim president from July into January
he's a nationally recognized computer
scientist entrepreneur public servant in
higher education leader he brings the
CMU extensive leadership an
administrative expertise not only in
advancing research and education within
and across disciplines but also in
translating research into technologies
and practices that benefit society prior
to coming to CMU jehanne Ian led the
National Science Foundation Directorate
for computer and information science and
engineering from 2011 to 2014 and prior
to that he was at the University of
Michigan he and I actually crossed paths
there as well Jillian serves as the
chair of the National National Research
Council's computer science and
telecommunications telecommunications
board sits on the Executive Committee of
the Council of competitiveness and is a
trustee on the Dietrich foundation he is
also a board member of the National
Center for Women in information
technology the advanced robotics
manufacturing Institute in the Allegheny
conference on community development
among others he has come to Pittsburgh
he has devoted himself he has thrown
himself into all parts of what's
happening here within the university in
the community we are grateful to have
him and so without further ado
thank you very much J for that kind
introduction
you didn't have to remind people that
you and I had a history at Michigan
especially after Monday nights at Mack
Villanova and and Michigan playing but
nonetheless um I'm also grateful to
Steve Colin's team for that picture that
they did the picture looks really good I
was just telling Mike Doyle it's amazing
what technology and Photoshop can do
these days anyway it is so good to be
with you this morning it is my pleasure
on behalf of my colleagues here at
Carnegie Mellon to welcome all of you to
the start of Carnegie Mellon
University's third annual celebration of
energy Week as one of CMU's most
important and high-profile celebrations
energy week brings together thought
leaders from around the world to discuss
the future of energy and the role of
interdisciplinary research and education
in informing this critical area this
morning I'm grateful to be joined by so
many distinguished colleagues and
leaders from within University and also
outside our campus who have contributed
to this work including several of our
prominent elected leaders these
representatives have been particularly
central to CMU's leadership in this area
providing invaluable support for
attracting federal and industry's
research and also advancing new models
of education today we are delighted to
be joined by our senior congressman Mike
Doyle representing Pittsburgh 14th
district also the newly minted US
congressman elect Connor lamb who's
making his first visit to campus since
his recent victory in Pittsburgh's 18th
district
welcome rich Fitzgerald CMU alum an
Allegheny County executive we're happy
to have rich with us and finally another
newly elected official Councilwoman
Erika Strasburg Berger who represents
Pittsburgh eighth district where I
actually live welcome all of you were
happy to have all of you with us thank
you very much for joining us and thank
you so much for your service to our
state to our city and also to our nation
I want to acknowledge also and thank J
Whittaker to trustee professor in the
engineering in energy engineering and
public policy as well as an appointment
in material science and engineering for
his leadership of the Scott Institute
for energy innovation which by the way
includes more than 150 researchers
across our campus I'm also grateful for
his role in planning districts Jordan
eCampus event and also to Anna SIF
kinome know many of you know Anna who's
associate director at the Institute and
the entire Scott Institute team for this
wonderful planning that they have done
for this for this event I also want to
acknowledge our former president
president emeritus Jerry Cohen who was
the founding director of the Scott
Institute for all that he has done not
only for Carnegie Mellon for also for
launching and nurturing the Scott
Institute thank you very much Jerry
please join me in thanking J Jerry Anna
and all the entire team at the
Scotland's
finally this week would not be possible
without our exceptional faculty alumni
and academic leaders including our
Provost who's here and a number of
keynote speakers and panelists who are
contributing to this event again we're
grateful for their contribution it is
entirely fitting that CMU is hosting
this week's important dialogues with our
top-ranked school in engineering and
computer science business and policy
Carnegie Mellon is proud of our
tradition of collaborating with
colleagues across disciplines to
consider complex societal problems in
particular we're at the center of
innovation and policy related to the
future of energy creating sustainable
and affordable energy alternatives
tackling the safety and reliability our
critical infrastructures and so much
more our work in this area has been made
possible by collaborations with the
private sector including companies in
Pittsburgh in the region as well as
universities foundations and community
institutions and Department of Energy's
National Energy Technology laboratories
these tremendous partners have been
instrumental in developing green
building technology transforming
brownfields funding and supporting our
dozens of energy related spinouts and
technology transfers and piloting new
clean energy technologies energy week is
all about bringing these partners
together to adapt as to adopt as well as
advocate a shared vision for the
economic and technological future of our
city and our region
make no mistake over the coming decades
the world must make fundamental
transformation in how the energy is
produced how its distributed
disseminated as well as how it's used
and consumed at this critical time for
our energy dependent world it's more
important than ever to reaffirm our
commitment to the pursuit of knowledge
and support for long term scientific
discovery and
engineering innovations energy week is
just one of the many campus traditions
that pay tribute to our commitment to
scientific discovery in engineering
innovations and cm roles role in finding
collaborative solutions for energy
challenges through research education
and equally important data-driven
policymaking is is critical we're
particularly delighted to welcome back
several alum number of them you will
meet later on today
one particular alum who is going to be
with us later today is our alumna and
mayor of San Juan Puerto Rico
carmen cruz who is going to be in a
conversation with our own Mayor Bill
Peduto later on this afternoon moderated
by our Provost Lori weingartz I'm very
much looking forward to that event later
on this evening there is truly something
for everyone during this event and I
encourage you to explore the energy week
and and especially create new
conversations and new dialogues with
colleagues that are attending this and
now it's my pleasure to introduce a
partner who's been helping to advance
CMU's energy ambitions for more than a
decade and who is a recognized national
leader in energy policy as well as a
member of the House Energy and Commerce
Committee Mike has been at the forefront
of all major energy policy innovations
including advocating for clean fossil
energy and strategies for climate change
he's been a champion for Pittsburg
position as a world leader in green
building technology in green chemistry
he's also worked hard to ensure that
energy research and innovation
translates into real opportunities and
better quality of life for all
Pittsburghers I can say so much more
about our congressman Mike Doyle from
his leadership in energy research and
innovation to his advocacy for federally
funded research to his leadership of the
robotics area and automation in Congress
for for two decades to his support for
stem initiatives and STEM education we
are truly fortunate to have Mike Doyle
representing
Pittsburgh and CMU and were grateful to
Mike for his service to our nation
please join me in extending a warm
welcome to Pittsburgh one of
Pittsburgh's greatest natural resources
Congressman Mike Boylan Mike Farnham
thank you very much it's always great to
be at CMU and very pleased to be here to
kick off energy week at CMU you know
western Pennsylvania has been at the
epicenter of our nation's energy
advances for more than 200 years since
before the nation's founding our state's
first coal mine was just across the Mon
on Mount Washington back then it was
known as coal hill and Pennsylvania
would go on to produce more coal than
any other state in America the nation's
first oil was found 70 miles north of
here over a century ago and today we're
smack dab in the middle of a shale
revolution and the development of
advanced energy technologies our
region's leadership in energy innovation
is unmatched in the country and now I'm
happy to say we're continuing that
tradition of revolutionary thinking and
action western Pennsylvania is in many
ways a microcosm of the country's
changing energy landscape we have
retiring coal plants and surrounding
communities that are affected by that
job loss we're witnessing the potential
retirement of nuclear plants we have gas
wells and pipelines and processing
plants but you know we also have energy
storage companies designing batteries
utilities that work with universities to
integrate more distributed generation
like wind and solar and companies that
make the panels and the turbines to
harness those new energy sources we are
a cutting-edge city that is integrated
district heating and cooling and micro
grids and a forward-thinking county
pursuing increasingly sustainable
transportation options and of course we
have groundbreaking research in
world-class universities like CMU
incubators businesses and national labs
like the NIT
in South Park this event bears witness
to that energy transformation the
policymakers business leaders
researchers and energy analysts convene
here by Carnegie Mellon aptly
demonstrate our region's and this
University's influence and leadership in
the energy world the panelists and
speakers that you'll hear from over the
coming days reflected the versity of
interest in opinions in the energy world
and that's a good thing I think it's far
too easy to silo oneself to interact
mostly with those who hold similar
perspectives but such intellectual
isolation usually hinders real progress
there are many hard questions we have to
solve in the energy and environmental
space and the best policymaking is
achieved through a lively rigorous
exchange of ideas and opinions informed
by facts and figures and findings
that's why energy week is so important
and why I couldn't be prouder of the
work that's being done here at CMU and
the Scott Institute earlier this year I
was fortunate to attend a roundtable
convened by the Scott Institute we heard
from dozens of CEOs business leaders
energy policy analysts and stakeholders
on the biggest barriers to improving
industrial energy efficiency especially
in manufacturing the Scott Institute in
my office are now working on a report
from that event and a number of bills to
address many of the concerns that were
raised to me that's a good example of
what this week's events can produce new
information and new ideas and especially
ways we can better collaborate with
stakeholders in this region and around
the country throughout my service in
Congress I've said that good
policymaking doesn't happen in a vacuum
throughout that time I've always been
proud of what I like to call western
Pennsylvania pragmatism consequently
we're all looking forward to hearing and
learning from our speakers today and
utilizing that information in our work
in Congress so I want to thank you all
for having me here today and thank the
Scott Institute for convening what is
going to be another great event and now
while I have the great pleasure of
introducing the new kid on the block
and you know rich and I were just at the
st. Patrick's Day parade with Governor
wolf and Senator Casey and we're all
standing there and then all of a sudden
up walks Connor lamb and all these young
ladies going Connor can we get a picture
with you and rich looked at me and he
says we're old news buddy if you just
being pushed aside and governor wolf
patted him on the shoulder and said
enjoy this while you can the honeymoon
short in our profession but I'll tell
you what Connor lamb is an impressive
young man he did something that a lot of
people across the country didn't think
can be done and he did it with a lot of
hard work a tremendous game plan this is
a born-and-bred western Pennsylvania guy
served our military in the Marines a
marine captain and a former assistant US
attorney somebody that's really grounded
I believe in western Pennsylvania
pragmatism which is what we need more
and more down in Washington DC people
that are going to be pragmatic willing
to work together to get things done I
think he's going to be a tremendous
addition to the Pennsylvania delegation
and next Thursday a week from tomorrow I
will have the privilege of introducing
him on the House floor when he gets
sworn in as the newest member of
Congress and the newest member of the
congressional delegation in Pennsylvania
it's with great pleasure that I
introduce to you
Connor lamb
[Applause]
good morning thank you all for having me
here I'm glad they're not putting up my
picture because I noticed I wore my only
tie today the same one that was in that
picture so maybe after I serve a few
terms I'll be able to get some more but
really appreciate you having me here
today as Mike mentioned before I got
into politics and before I came back
home to Pittsburgh I had the honor of a
lifetime of serving as an officer in the
US Marines and I'm still in the marine
reserves and sometimes if you haven't
served in the military people forget or
they would ask me you know why do we
have a Marine Corps when we already have
an army you know both forces seem to
serve on land they drive around in tanks
they carry rifles they do a lot of the
same things well the reason is because
the Marines are designed and trained
specifically to move very far very fast
in a moment of crisis or emergency
so after 9/11 the Marines were already
out on a ship in the middle of the
Indian Ocean and they got to Afghanistan
first you know within two or three weeks
after 9/11 and they were on the ground
already penetrating that territory in a
space of time that the army could never
do because the Army is larger and their
equipment is heavier and they're
stationed back on land in the United
States they're not sitting out there on
ships in the middle middle of the ocean
the reason I bring this up today is
because as part of our training as part
of our ongoing learning and the way that
we prepare our Marines we're always
looking for things ways to cut the load
to make us lighter make us faster make
us more efficient and effective on the
battlefield and now secretary Jim mattis
who was a general during my time on
active duty used to talk about
unleashing us from the tether of fuel
how Marines could be so much more
effective and we could do so much more
and go places faster if we had more
reliable and more efficient sources of
energy because we do have to power the
tanks we do have to power all the
incredible communications and satellite
equipment and computer equipment that we
have
and that does always operate like a
tether holding us back
now unfortunately when we have a complex
engineering problem that requires a lot
of research and thought and intellect
when we have problems like that in the
energy sector
no one says send in the Marines that's
not what we're for
Marines are called jarheads and as
somebody from another service once told
me they said a lot of times the jar is
empty
but thankfully we have the Department of
Energy we have experts like you who can
solve that problem for us and put us to
work
so when I go down to Washington I will
have my eye very closely on sources of
funding for scientific research for
energy research and I hope to join a
proud tradition of elected officials
here in western Pennsylvania who have
pushed for that over many years
Congressman Mike Doyle is one of them
he's a great champion of this funding
and he's part of the reason why when you
see an initial budget proposal from the
current White House that would cut
funding for the National Science
Foundation by 30% that when they passed
the spending bill last week that funding
was actually increased and the funding
for the Office of Science within the
Department of Energy was increased by a
lot because we need it China is
investing massive amounts of money in
energy research and in artificial
intelligence and the whole wave of the
future for reason because that future is
up for grabs and I intend for you the
United States to win that race I intend
for western Pennsylvania to play a
leading role in that race and we are in
fact part of a proud tradition
congressman Doyle and I are both
preceded by congressman Jack Murtha my
fellow marine and congressman Billy coin
all Irish Americans as it turns out
probably none of us would be much use
with a circuit board or behind the
computer screen but the Irish have the
gift of gab and so we can go down to the
halls of Congress and make the best case
that you'd ever imagine for something
that we don't even ourselves understand
but that's just something the good Lord
gave us so I'm proud today to introduce
another great Irish American politician
who bridges this divide because he is
also an engineer and a
of your school as well as my high school
Central Catholic rich Fitzgerald has
been such a powerful and great and
inspirational leader for us here in
Allegheny County he has moved the ball
so far down the field in so many areas
including the development of our energy
resources and supporting great
institutions like this one so without
further ado rich please
[Applause]
thanks Connor that's cuz I couldn't get
into law school so that's all
so the forum you're making me speak
between Connor Lam and Erica
Strassburger the new kids the new
exciting kids on the block
that's okay did we count all those votes
from Washington County that you got okay
let make sure anyway it is great to be
here it is great to be again at my alma
mater who has done and continues to do
so many great things around innovation
specifically around energy but on so
many different levels
congressman Doyle talked about the
history of western Pennsylvania and
where energy is and while that goes back
over a couple of centuries I almost feel
like we are still at the beginning of a
great technological revolution in the
energy field we know that changes are
coming so fast in the job market and
jobs that exist today may not exist
tomorrow and things like transportation
but one thing that's never going to go
away and continues to increase is our
insatiable need for energy and the
changes that are that are continuing to
come around that that energy need also
are matched with our need for
sustainability our need for our impact
on the climate our need for our impact
in communities and what they are and as
congressman Doyle and and congressman
elect Liam talked about you know there's
a pragmatism about solving problems and
while politics certainly enters into a
lot of the decisions that those of us in
elected office make science still
matters and you can't change those laws
of physics and those laws of of
thermodynamics etc that are part and
parcel of what we do so because of the
great research coming out of this
institution
you know Pittsburgh and western
Pennsylvania are on an upward trajectory
we're in a good space for folks that are
looking for jobs and economic
opportunities and it's because of what
comes out of this university that
thought of that occurs and a lot of that
happens it's Mike mentioned you know
what we're seeing around manufacturing
you know the shield production around
what's going to be happening here over
the next couple of decades and how we
can do that in a sustainable safe
environmentally friendly way as a
challenge we're all faced with and all
the choices that we have in energy from
solar and wind and nuclear to the fossil
fuels to geothermal the hydro etc are
things that will have an impact on on
how we pay for things how we produce
them how we transmit them how we store
them all those all those things that you
deal with and you give us the advice to
try to make good policies that make
sense for the region and for the
community so I congratulate Farnum
number one on his presidency I think I
can't tell you how what a great choice
that was for not just for this great
university but for this region in
general so I want to thank you in fact
the University Board of Trustees for
having the great wisdom to make that
selection and the partnership that we
have in this community is NaN I don't
think there's any place in the country
that has that type of partnership of
working together across the governmental
spectrum at the federal state local
level our universities our business
community our labor unions our
foundations community groups all the
folks that have a stake those
stakeholders get a seat at the table and
we work together we work together to
solve problems and that's what you're
going to be doing over the next couple
of days as as energy week continues so
let me now introduce another new person
and that's a great thing about
Pittsburgh we've got some really new
dynamic leaders who are who are coming
on the scene over the next of the next
year you've met Connor and we know it
with congressman elect Liam it's going
to be doing in Washington but right here
in this very district we have another
new leader
Erica Strassburger and I guess I should
say new but not so new because she's
been doing this work as the former
councilman Diane Gilman's chief of staff
for the last four years and I know the
great work she's done working with the
university working with our neighbors in
our community and what does the impact
of what happens
the national level what does that mean
to us right here in our neighborhoods
Erica is absolutely poised to have the
expertise to be able to you know
influence how that's going to affect us
she worked in the environmental
community for many years so her area of
expertise is something we can certainly
need certainly use so without further
ado let me bring up our newly elected
getting sworn in tomorrow
councilman elect err Erica Strassburger
Erica thank you rich and thank you to
CMU in the Scott Institute for having me
here today I'm thrilled to be here and
as mentioned as the council member elect
for the district you're currently
sitting in I want to offer you a warm
welcome to see any CMU's energy week and
to district 8 so collaboration you've
heard it from Farnum you've heard the
word cooperation here today here today
this morning collaboration really is a
hallmark of Carnegie Mellon I've seen it
firsthand it's an institution that truly
walks the walk on multidisciplinary
cross pollination so it should come as
no surprise that collaboration has
extended beyond the borders of this
campus to include the likes of the city
of Pittsburgh Carnegie Mellon and the
city have collaborated to the to build a
smarter more energy independent city
allowing Pittsburgh to serve as an urban
test laboratory for technology
advancement energy innovation and smart
mobility using artificial intelligence
technology CMU's traffic 21 and metro 21
smart cities Institute has worked
closely with the city of Pittsburgh on
its scalable urban traffic control
project which is an amazing project that
you might have even experienced or
driven through here in the city
converting traffic signals to a system
that senses oncoming traffic and
actually changes its cycle based on the
most efficient way to move traffic
through busy intersections in the pilot
project there was an impressive 40%
reduction in vehicle idling time and 21
percent reduction in carbon emissions
from idling in addition CMU is remaking
cities Institute and the city
partner to transform its standard
streetlights to LED powered streetlights
increasing energy efficiency to create
well-lit communities this is the kind of
collaboration that has again allowed the
city of Pittsburgh to be the testing lab
for new technologies and just a few of
many examples throughout the decades of
this kind of partnership and as the city
and the region worked to attract new
talent and growth and investment that
the region desperately needs
I'm also very mindful of the growth the
rapid growth that's experienced that
we're experiencing just beyond these
doors in the East End neighborhoods of
Pittsburgh and we can be a model for
smart growth for the region and beyond
if we do it right Pittsburgh has begun
to invest in an electric elite of
vehicles including charging stations
that are now operational and one of the
nation's first electric police cruisers
the city is improving the energy
efficiency of its government buildings
following the lead of CMU which in 2003
opened the city of the nation's first
residence hall that was LEED certified
and now boasts 13 green buildings and by
investing in alternative modes of
transportation the city is encouraging
its residents to use a bicycle or public
transit or to walk instead of driving a
car
so as Pittsburgh strives to grow while
also meeting its resiliency and
sustainability goals I'm confident in
the potential for us to do so while in
close collaboration with CMU and I truly
look forward to being part of that
partnership so welcome again to energy
CMU energy week thank you again for
having me today and now I have the
distinct pleasure to welcome Anna Siskin
with the Scott Institute for energy
innovation here at CMU Anna is the
organizer of the CMU energy week 2018
and will tell you a little bit more
about the week's exciting event so
please give her a huge round of applause
for all of her work
good morning everyone so nice to see all
of you here I have a few slides I'm
doing a little bit of housekeeping this
morning but I definitely wanted to start
with a welcome welcome to CMU welcome to
energy week we're very glad to have you
I know that many of you traveled from
far and wide and we appreciate having
you here so what we have ahead of us is
pretty extraordinary I put together a
few numbers because that's what CMU does
really well so I'll take a moment and
I'll give you a few of those as of last
night about a about a thousand attendees
have registered about 300 companies
hundreds of hours of volunteer time as
well as staff time and and those of us
putting this together
91 speakers 45 sessions
38 student posters 30 startup companies
19 investors 17 faculty members
showcasing their work 13 awesome
sponsors thank you very much to our
sponsors 12 new energy fellows that
we'll be announcing 10 student teams
competing in our competition nine panels
eight keynotes over three days so some
pretty staggering numbers but I think
the really important thing that I want
to mention before I get into the
housekeeping is really not about numbers
but it's about you it's about all of you
and each and every one of you that came
this all this way it's important to our
work to have you here to have you in
Pittsburgh at this moment in time so the
conversations that you have I hope are
transformative to the work that you do
when you get back to your regular lives
in all those other places but I'm glad
that you've decided to invest your time
with us over the next three days so we
hope that all of your time here is
really extraordinary next slide there
are a lot of people to thank this is the
sort of working group Advisory Committee
so these are folks that I called it's a
late time of night and ask questions
about panels and topics and and things
that we could really work on quite a few
of these folks are actually here in the
room
right now Jeff McDaniel Bruce Gephardt
grant Irvin Bob Borzello I know you're
all here so thank you to those folks
special thanks also to our conference
and Event Services team our
communications team and our interns and
I want to shout out especially to a
couple of people who've done some
extraordinary work this is Jenny Delaney
and Michael Harding who've both put in
timeless efforts to make this work and
of course there's Amanda King who's our
communications analyst you might have
gotten one or 20 emails from her but we
are very glad to have you here an
important part of the team so the Scott
Institute you might have seen our
building if not we have tours that are
happening later this week
it's an extraordinary building about a
hundred and seven thousand square feet
and it's a place for people to come
together and it includes housing the
Scott Institute so our mission is really
to bring together those 150 faculty that
we talked about for research and
strategic partnerships public policy and
education so a few highlights of things
that you'll see this week as well as
things that are happening with the Scott
Institute again we're highlighting those
the faculty that are working in energy
already bringing them together with new
opportunities we do programming like
this it will actually be launching an
energy consortium in 2019 that's
something we'll be talking about later
this week we have competitions and we
inspire students and teams to have
innovation and entrepreneurship as a
part of their education here we want it
to be a part of their experience we do
that through the Allegheny clean tech
prize which will be on Friday as well as
the investor forum which is a new thing
we're doing tomorrow morning and then we
host academic centers and research we'll
be announcing results from our first
year of the power sector carbon index
will be launching or relaunching I
should say the Green Design Institute
that'll be on Thursday night we're
looking at pilots to do districts to do
testing a district scale and deployment
those are things that will be coming up
and we're also I'm going to be launching
an energy challenge and that will be in
2019 more
so this week in particular we have some
exceptional speakers many of you are
registered for them in to highlight in
particular this afternoon Don Anderson
will be here from Blackstone Group he's
the head of the the sustainability
director for the largest privately held
real estate trust and Praja Mori is here
she'll be our first speaker and she'll
be next this afternoon we have a
conversation between our Mayor Bill
Peduto and Mayor Harmon Yulin Cruz from
San Juan Puerto Rico a senior alumna and
we have 9 panels across those couple of
days on Thursday Dave Danielson from
breakthrough energy ventures will be
here that's bill gates operation and we
have some exciting announcements and
work that we're doing together
Randy gentry who's actually here in the
front will be giving a talk tomorrow
afternoon at 4:30
Alex Lasky from Opower which was
recently purchased by Oracle we'll be
talking about entrepreneurship tomorrow
afternoon we're doing a reception in our
newly minted LEED Gold Scott Hall
facility I mentioned already that we're
doing an investor forum but at the same
time we'll have a fair so that people
can see and touch all of the
technologies that these startups have
they've come in from a five-state region
and we'll be showcasing faculty work
that in many cases you may not have seen
before
finally on Friday morning at 10 o'clock
Andrew place will be here he's a CMU
alum and he's also the vice chairman for
the Pennsylvania PUC Chris white who is
the newly named CEO from philips
Lighting will be attending and balaji
john apathy will be here in the evening
to talk about energy and equity and
inclusivity
we'll have tours will have the allegheny
clean tech mm-hmm
uprize during the day so there'll be
activities in this room throughout the
week a special thank you to all of our
sponsors
this event would certainly not be
possible without all of their support
and if you are on social media these are
some tags that you can use CMU energy
you'll see this CMU energy come up in a
at different places including in our
real housekeeping so we've gone to a
digital format for asking questions
today so we have an app called Salado
you can simply go onto your browser type
in slider com
it'll ask you for an event code and you
put in pound CMU energy and that will
allow you to ask questions during a
session so it's important to actually
put the questions in towards the
beginning will be moderating them and
the moderators for each of the panels
this afternoon will be able to see those
questions as they come in our event app
is biz veau so many of you have that
already a great way to keep up to date
and connect with each other and just a
reminder to please silence your
cellphone's if you have not done that
already so with that thank you very much
for being with us I'm glad to have you
here and I have the distinct pleasure to
introduce our interim provost Lori
weingartz so our guest speaker Anne has
come in and I see that we're running a
few minutes early so why don't we take
about a five or ten minute break and
we'll allow them to get back and we'll
start promptly at 11 o'clock
thank you again